ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมา
พบกับพวกเราในวีดีโอโป้
ชายอยู่ในคลาสค่ะไปแล้วค่ะก็รู้ไหมคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะทำไมใจร้อนจัง
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันนี้วันอาทิตย์นะคะวัน
อาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 27  5
ค่ะค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะปี
คศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
แต่ตอนนี้วันเสาร์จะ
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ที่ 26
ค่ะเดือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะให้นี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28 ค่ะเรือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา
จะ
13:00 น
กี่นาทีคะบ่ายโมง 55 นาทีค่ะหลายโมง 55
นาทีน้องก็เป็นเวลากลางวันที่เวลากลางวัน
ตอนบ่ายนะคะตอนบ่ายผู้หญิงกินข้าวหรือยัง
คะครูหญิงกินข้าวเสร็จแล้วค่ะอิ่มแล้วครู
ฟ้าล่ะคะกินข้าวหรือยัง
ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลยค่ะกูหญิงเอากูไปที่
อยู่ไหม
หิวข้าวค่ะหิวอยู่ข้างไปกินข้าวค่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรครูฟ้านะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ที่บ้าน
สมัยกูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านนะเดี๋ยว Video ถ้า
เสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าก็ไปกินข้าวที่บ้าน
โอเคค่ะไหมอยู่ที่บ้านอยากกินข้าวง่ายๆไง
เพราะว่าอะไรเพราะว่าอยู่บ้านเนาะอยู่
บ้านเนี่ยสบาครูหญิงแหละอยู่ Condominium
ใช่ไหม Apartment  Condominium
น้องมันเล็กๆ
ไม่ดีหรือไม่ดีอยู่ที่บ้านเดี๋ยวโอนจอย
เออ
ใช่พรทุกคนจะไม่คนที่อยู่กรุงเทพเนี่ยก็
คิดฉะนั้นทุกคนและก็จะคิด
อย่างผู้หญิงอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมมันก็จะอ้อคิด
คิดคิดโอ้โอครูหญิงเนี่ยอยากมีบ้านบ้าน
ใหญ่ๆบ้านที่ไหนใช้ทุกคนก็คิดครูฟ้าครู
ฟ้าอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านแต่
ถ้าเป็นบ้านคุณพ่อคุณแม่
ถูกต้องค่ะเป็นบ้านของคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไว้ของ
ครูฝาเนาะผู้ฟ้าก็คิดคิดคิดอยากมีบ้าน
เหมือนกันใช่ไหมถ้าอยาก oof อาญาอยากมี
บ้านอยากซื้อบ้านเกิด
ทุกคน
ก็คิดอยากจะมีบ้านเราเรียกว่าบ้านในฝัน
แต่บ้านในฝันก็คือเราคิดแบบอยากจะมีบ้าน
ที่ไหน
ใหญ่ๆเล็กๆ
เป็นยังไงอ่ะซึ่งวีดีโอนี้นะคะครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเราก็จะมาบอกนักเรียนว่าเรา
เนี่ยอยากมีบ้านยังไงแบบไหนเนอะคือเรา
อยากดูบ้านแบบใช่มั้ยพูดถ้าจ่ายรถไฟฟ้า
อาจจะอยากมีบ้านที่ไหนอย่างนี้ล่ะ
มีบ้านในฝันน้องบ้านในฝันที่ครูฟ้ากิ๊กๆ
เนี่ยเป็นยังไงบ้านในฝันของครูหญิงเป็น
ยังไงนะเดี๋ยวเราจะมาให้นักเรียนดูนะคะ
แต่ว่าของผู้หญิงเอ่อ Share  screen ก่อน
แนะ
ได้เลยอ่ะเราก็จะบอกนักเรียนมาบ้านในฝัน
มีบ้างเรา
ใช่ป่ะ
มีไม่น่า
ทุกคนมีเนาะบ้านในฝันใช่มั้ยทุกคนอย่าง
อ้า
นักเรียนก็บอกเราได้นะนักเรียนดูวีดีโอ
เสร็จแล้วก็บอกเราได้นะคะอะอันนี้นะคะมา
แล้ว
แฮชวีนติดต่อโอเคต้องล่างขึ้นไปนะคะ
ถึง Share  screen แล้วเนาะ
โอเค
ไอ้ครูฟ้านะบ้านในฝันของครูฟ้าเป็นยังไง
อย่าให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยวาดให้นักเรียนดูได้
ค่ะแป๊บนึงนะกูป๊าทำไมอ่ะ Apple  Pencil
มันไม่ค่อยมีอะหรอสักครู่วิตะมินิร้อนหอย
รอหน่อย
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะคะค่ะได้ค่ะได้ค่ะ
ได้มั้ยแอปเปิ้ลเพนซิลไม่นะคะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นคะอ่ะกลับมาค่ะกลับมาประมาณเดี๋ยวคุย
Share  screen แป๊บนึงนะคะอ่ะแต่ว่า
แอปเปิ้ลเพนซิลของครูฟ้า Connect แล้ว
แล้วก็กลับมาบ้านในฝันของเราสองคนได้หาก
คุณเอ้
โอเค
โอเคให้ครูฟ้า
วาดบ้านในฝันของครูฟ้าก่อนก่อนที่ฟ้าจะ
วาดเนี่ยผู้หญิงมีคำถามถามว่าอะไรครูฟ้า
อยากมีบ้านไหน
ที่ไหนก็ได้นะภูฟ้าไม่ใช่แค่ประเทศไทยนะ
หรือว่าไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯไม่ใช่พัทยามีฟ้า
อยากมีบ้านที่ไหน
ครูฟ้าอยากมีบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯค่ะคุณหญิง
เอ่อที่กรุงเทพนะโอเคมือแล้วบ้านครูฟ้าจะ
เป็นยังไง
นักเรียนก็ต้องรอดูขาใส่ค่ะก็เลย
แน่นอนว่าว่างก็ต้องมี
เดี๋ยวหา
อะไรเฮายันอะไรฮะสามเหลี่ยมค่ะนักเรียนพอ
หลังคา
ถูกต้องหาหลังคาหลังคาแล้วครูฟ้าอยากอยาก
ออกมาบ้านน้องดูฝ้าอยากมีบ้านกี่ชั้นน่ะ
1ชั้น2ชั้น3ชั้น4ชั้นถ้าชั้นกูฟ้าอย่างมี
บ้าน 2 ชั้นน่ะอ๋ออันนี้เหรอเค้าบ้าน 2
13 ไหมคะอ๋อ
ครูฟ้าอยากมีบ้าน 2 ชั้นใช่ไหมอ่า
นะแมะสายนี้ชั้น 1 นี้ชั้น 2 มิติว่าไทย
ได้ไฟฟ้าลบนะคะได้นะอ่า
เดี๋ยวๆฟ้ามีอะไรฮะ
ข้างบน
ข้างบนหลังคาเนี่ยค่ะอันนี้อะไหล่คะ
หน้าตาต่างค่ะออมีหน้าต่างบนหลังเช้าน่ะ
ก็แปลว่าต้องมีห้องอยู่ข้างบนหลังคาไหม
โอ้โหแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ย
หลังคาบ้านครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
มีเนาะหลังคาบ้านเนี่ยหาหลังคาบ้านครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าอยากมีหลังคาบ้านสีอะไรอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าอยากมีหลังคาบ้านสีสีดำค่ะห้าสีดำ
ว่าใส่สีดำได้ไหมคะ
สีดำขอดูฟ้าใหญ่มีหลังคาบ้านสีดำ
สีแล้วอาสาอยากทาบ้านแต่บ้านคู่ฟ้านะลูก
ค้าอยากทาบ้านสีอะไรอ่ะสีครีมค่ะขอให้มี
สี
ครีมก็เหมือนๆสีขาวเนาะคล้ายๆกันใช่อ้ะสี
ครีมกับสีขาวแล้วครูฟ้าอยากมีบ้านใช่ไหม
คะหรือว่าฟ้า
กูไม่อยากมีบ้านใหญ่ค่ะผู้หญิงยังนี่ว่า
จะเติมบ้านโอ้บ้านครูฟ้ายังไม่เสร็จเนาะ
แต่ผู้หญิงมีคำถามใน
หลังคาใช่มั้ยนี้เป็นหลังคานะหลังคาจำ
หลังคาสีดำสีดำสีดำ
เข็มโอเคค่ะ
หลังคานัดนี้ก็จะเป็นบ้านใช่ไหมค่ะอันนี้
เป็นชั้นสองแล้วก็นี้ชั้น 1
ลืม
บ้าน
เดี๋ยวมึงนะไม่ถนัด
นี้จะเป็นหน้าต่างมีอะไรเอาหน้าต่าง
หน้าต่างหน้าต่างแล้วก็อันนี้ก็หน้าต่าง
อ๋อ
หนูมีหน้าต่างหน้าต่างและจากหน้าต่างหลาย
บานมากๆบ้านครูฟ้า
ต้องหนาอันนี้อะไรคะอันนี้รถค่ะขอรถขอแปล
ว่าตรงนี้ตรงนี้ก็คือที่จอดรถเหรอคะครู
ฟ้าที่จอดรถน่ะ 2 คันเลยตอกอะไรจะบอกเลย
ว่าอยากมีรถ 2 คัน
รถต้องหั่น
แล้วอ่ะแต่ถ้าบ้านสมัยตรงเนี้ยข้างหน้า
บ้านครูฟ้า
ฟ้าอยากมีอะไรไหม
ถ้าอยากมีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ค่ะ
อันนี้จะเป็นทางเดินขาเอาไว้เดินนะนัก
เรียน
เดินเท่าไหร่ก็นี้จะเป็นต้นไม้
อย่าหมาเดี๋ยวเราอยากมีดอกไม้ไหมดอกไม้
เหรออยากมีหรอกหน้าบ้านอย่างมีดอกไม้ไหม
ดูออกไหมเนี่ยดอกไม้ใช่ห่ากูพยางค์มีดอก
ไม้
ดอกไม้
แล้วอยากมีอะไรอีกคะบ้านในฝันของครูฟ้ามี
อะไรอีก
อยากมี
คุณ
อยากมีน้ำพุอ่ะเขา
น้ำพุ
นะ
คะเรียกว่าจะวาดน้ำพุนะฮะโอเคเดี๋ยวให้
ครูฟ้าว่าน้ำพุค่ะเดี๋ยวคุณหญิงหาน้ำพุ
ให้นักเรียนดูด้วยนะคะ
น่ารัก
นี้ก็เป็นน้ำพุแล้วก็จะมีน้ำลงมา
นี่
ค่ะนักเรียน
ใส่เป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมน้ำพุงอะมีน้ำพุหน้า
บ้าน
น้ำพุหน้าบ้านแล้วก็
มีอะไรอีกดีบ้านในฝันหมดหรือยัง
อยากครูฟ้าจะมีรั้วบ้านไหมไม่มีบ้านเราก็
มีแบบรั้ว
ไม่
ใช่ผู้หญิงตัวอย่างมีรั้วว่านโอเค
รั้วบ้านให้ไหมว่าคนไทยเนี่ยต้องมีรั้วนะ
คะค่ะทรายใส่บ้านนักเรียนบางประเทศบ้าน
ไม่มีรู้ว่าเนาะแต่ผ่านคนไทยอย่างคนไทย
ชอบมีรั้วบ้านไส้ค่ะนั่นแหละรั้วบ้าน
รั้วบ้านหานักเรียนค่ะ
รั้วบ้าน
นี่แหล่ะแม่บ้านในฝันน่ะมีอะไรอีกดีของ
ครูฟ้าของฟ้า
ว่าจะมีอะไร
หมดหรือยังบ้านในฝันของครูฟ้า
หมดแล้วหมดแล้วไม่มีอะไรวะเงินนี่เป็น
บ้านในฝันนะคะครูฟ้าอยากมีบ้านใหญ่ๆ 2
ชั้นนอนแล้วก็มีคะอันนี้โรงรถนะคะมีน้ำพุ
ทำไมแล้วก็มีทางเดินแล้วก็มีต้นไม้ต้นไม้
ดอกไม้ดอกไม้มีหน้าต่างหน้าต่างหน้าต่าง
หน้าต่างหน้าต่างหน้าต่างเยอะมาก
เยอะ
หลังคาสมัยหลังคาสีดำนะคะนี่เป็นบ้านใน
ฝันของอยู่ที่
กรุงเทพฯในบ้านดึกลงป๊าไปหากรุงเทพมหาน
เยอะอุบาชน
อ่ะต่อไปบ้านในฝันของครูหญิงล่ะไม่ต้อง
เขียวๆเปลี่ยนเลยอ่ะเคลียร์ออนะคะอ่าบ้าน
ในฝันของครูหญิงใช่ไหมครูฟ้าให้กับผู้
หญิงมีอะไรบ้างล่ะมีฝันของตู้หญิงครูหญิง
เนี่ยนะคะอยากมีบ้าน
บนภูเขาค่ะโห
และก็บ้านบนภูขาวใช่ไหมเราก็มีบ้าน
อยากดีบ้านอยู่บนเขาค่ะ
เดี๋ยวแบบนี้เลย
อันนี้เป็นหรอกให้นักเรียนดูเฉยๆไงอยากมี
เชียงใหม่อยากมีบ้านบนภูเขาที่เชียงใหม่
ค่ะครูฟ้าดีมากผู้หญิงเชียงใหม่อากาศดีนะ
คะรายเชียงใหม่เนี่ยประมาณ
20 องศาเซลเซียสใช่ไหมสบายๆไม่ร้อนไม่
หนาว
ดีมากผู้หญิงบ้านไอ้ห่าแล้ว
บ้านผู้หญิงเนี่ย
อยู่บนภูเขาใช่ไหมทราย
ผู้หญิงอ่ะไหนอะไรนะฟ้าอยากมีบ้านแบบไหน
ใหญ่ไหมดีหรือว่าเล็กวิ่งยากมีบ้านไม่
ใหญ่แล้วก็ไม่เล็กพอดีพอดีกลางๆมาแล้วก็
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยสถานจับเวลาหลังคาบ้านกูหญิง
เนี่ยสีฟ้าอ่ะกูป๊าหลังคาบ้านสีฟ้า
ทรายแล้วก็ก็คือผู้หญิงก็จะทาบ้านสีฟ้า
เหมือนกันมีคะคือฟ้าผู้หญิงชอบสีฟ้าเหรอ
ใจค่ะผู้หญิงชอบสีฟ้า
แต่ไม่ชอบครูฟ้านะคะ
สาวๆเนาะแล้วก็บ้านในฝันของครูหญิง
เนี่ยนะกูฟ้ามีแค่ 1 ชั้นหรอสรรค์เท่า
นั้นผู้หญิงชอบบ้าน 1 ชั้นหรออร่อยค่ะชอบ
บ้าน 1 ชั้นเนาะแล้วก็ข้างหน้าตรงนี้มี
ประตูมีเพื่อนดูบ้านแล้วก็มีหน้าต่างนอก
เหมือนภูฟ้านะหน้าต่างหรือเปล่าเนื้อเพลง
อาจารย์ใจขาดแต๊กบ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมีอัน
นี้ด้วยเข้ากูฟ้า
อะไหล่
นี่
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าลอง Fire  Ice  the
long ซ้ายผู้หญิงเอาไว้ให้สรรพกรมาแล้ว
ค่ะชายชายจะเอาเชียงใหม่บางครั้งอาจจะแบบ
หนาวใช่ไหมบนภูเขาอาจจะแบบ 10 องศา
เซลเซียสก็มีไฟที่บ้านก็จะมีปล่องไฟ
เลยก็ให้สปาโค้ชมานะคะเราก็ข้างบ้านใช่
ไหมข้างบ้านตรงนี้นะตรงนี้นุ้ยตรงนี้นะ
ข้างบ้านตรงนี้นะคะอยากมีอะไรผู้หญิงนี่
จะมีอันนี้ให้ภูฟ้า
กูฟ้ารู้มั้ยอะไรอ่ะข้อควรทอหน่อยเฮ้ย
อะไรอ่ะอะไรอ่ะ
วิ่งยาวมีสระว่ายน้ำยังไงข้างหม้ายอยากมี
สระว่ายน้ำอันนี้ก็เป็นบันไดเนาะบันได
บันไดลงสระใช่มีสระว่ายน้ำ
สระว่ายน้ำว่าดีค่ะผู้หญิงดีๆทรายครูฟ้า
ทำไมครูฟ้ามาบ้านครูหญิงก็มาว่ายน้ำได้
ดีนะคะ
ไฟ
อ่ะผู้หญิงก็จะมีมีโต๊ะใช่ไหมมีโต๊ะ
แล้วก็มีเก้าอี้
[เพลง]
เอาไว้สำหรับเวลากับตอนเช้าๆใช่ไหมหกโมง
เช้าเนี่ยก็มานั่งแล้วก็ดื่มกาแฟกิน
พี่แจน Witch ใช่ไหมคะอาหารเช้าแต่ว่า
ต้องเป็นโต๊ะและเก้าอี้ที่อยู่นอกบ้านจะ
มาใส่อยู่ข้างนอกบ้านไม่อยู่ไม่ได้อยู่ใน
บ้านใหม่ๆ
ก็ดีค่ะมีโต๊ะมีเก้าอี้แล้วมีอะไรอีกผู้
หญิงแล้วก็ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าตรงนี้ก็จะมีจะ
ปลูกต้นไม้นะจะปลูกต้นมะม่วงมะม่วง
มะม่วงจะมีต้นมะม่วงต้นมะม่วงต้นใหญ่ใช่
ไหมใจค่ะแล้วก็ข้างหลังข้างหลังบ้านมา
ข้างหลังบ้านเนาะข้างหลังบ้านเนี่ยนะคุณ
ฟ้า
กูอีกก็จะมี
สตรอเบอร์รี่ค่ะ
ซูมนักเรียน
สู้ๆบุรีรัมย์ที่ผู้หญิงก็จะปลูก
ติด
ต่อเบอร์รี่เอาซอมบี้ไม่ใช่สีส้มนะคะสี
แดงสีแดง
ข้างหลังบ้านและก็จะปลูกรอเบอร์รี่
Strawberry สตอเบอรี่
มาสวยครูฟ้ามาว่ายน้ำเสร็จก็เดินไปข้าง
หลังบ้านแล้วก็เอ่อสตอเบอรี่กินอันนี้ก็
คือบ้านในฝันของครูหญิงใช่ไหมหมด
แล้วใช่ไหมที่ยังมีอะไรอีกไหมผู้หญิง
ไม่อยากมีแล้วอ่ะหมดแล้วแล้วก็จะมีบ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะมีบ้านสีฟ้าแล้วก็อันนี้มีสระ
ว่ายน้ำข้างบ้านและมีสระว่ายน้ำมีโต๊ะ
โต๊ะเก้าอี้สำหรับดื่มกาแฟจะไม่มีต้น
มะม่วง
ข้างหลังบ้านก็จะปลูกมีสตรอว์เบอร์รี
อ่า
หลังคาบ้านก็จะมีกล่องไฟนะนี้เป็นบ้านใน
ฝัน
ต้องเป็นงานในฝันของผู้หญิงคุยยังอยู่
เชียงใหม่นะคะครูฟ้าอยากอยู่กรุงเทพฯ
เทพชัยค่ะใส่แล้วบ้านในฝันของนักเรียน
เป็นยังไงนะสีอะไรใช่ไหมก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อน
เนาะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ